I can't tell you what happened but I can
show you my clothes it's me welcome to a
new day today we're starting off early I
have my call time as an hour it's 8:00
in the morning I'm gonna have breakfast
and it should be another crazy day I'm
really nervous because I don't know
what's gonna happen
toast
I call a pot
good shot the weather in UK where I live
is so [ __ ] so you come to LA and it's
like a nice Swedish summer all the time
Oh time to look pretty so sexy pants the
Builder can he build it
[Music]
yes he can Wow
I literally have to go but I just
noticed this green button hell yeah Milo
goes it starts now new crazy day bye
there are close already waiting I have
to redo my walkout movie magic didn't
work they're calling again I'm at the
YouTube space it is a big space it's
gonna be interviewed over there about
secret stuff that no one knows what it
is I rat out right all right this is how
YouTube looks like behind the scenes
need to put your eye in there too that's
cool
it stays so cool we just wrapped up time
for lunch they told me that we're not
gonna do anything weird today but I have
a hotel I got please call help I need
help right now
I'm scared
is this a good look for me
this look good leave a comment
mr. Nam
it was just a face is it nap now hey
we're not framing on this are you now
it's for you
I'm over here just got burned [ __ ] mr.
notion yep
right behind you yep another day what
happened you will know in I don't know
when this comes that so I did some
behind-the-scenes stuff and now I'm
gonna head back home oh my god it's my
favorite
I just finished another day I'm heading
back home
I can't as always I can't tell you what
happened but I can show you my clothes
it got a lot Messier I actually got to
wash up but I don't even know I was also
at YouTube space and they gave me this
backpack still waiting for the plaque
but let's check out what it is I can
only what is this oh my god they made it
this is hand done that's awesome
all right so it says Felix just because
it's fun doesn't make it easy we're
sorry to see you rocket and we're
cheering for you every step of the way
love your friends again it's so sweet
the streamys is happening today I don't
know I couldn't make it because I'm
doing this other thing headphones
headphones for when you want to sleep
but partynextdoor is too loud let's see
what else is in here
a bottle a YouTube pack napkins youtube
napkins my favorite napkins I want to
hit you
day four day six I mean done all right
let's go say hi to Marx yeah we're gonna
head out for lunch I need to get out of
these pants man honey I'm your iPhone
cover is ten anything so Martha's
editing my vlogs now yeah cuz I'm away
all day and I have two friends who's
editing the other ones runaway Brad and
cat Woodson worm I'll just write who's
editing the video while I'm gone in the
description
what up fellow gangsters are you ready
to hit the streets let's let's go this
way we're going for lunch did I just say
we're going for lunch when we go for
dinner I'm tired I wear my sunglasses at
night so at Kim I'm vlogging the vlog
I think Martha's taking me to some
neighborhood some bad neighborhood and
killing me right there where is his
restaurant
hey people who look at you so weird when
you vlog they were like what is he doing
mine said were you taking me
alright alright rat I ran around
right we're here this is the vegan place
Organic plant-based cuisine that's how
you know you're in LA
don't die we're going back we're gonna
chillax relax oh cool and I'll shoot
some ball oh my god it's Calvin Calvin
Harris
I love Calvin Harris so much there's no
light on this road how will we cross
this is crazy
oh my god
what did he yell [ __ ] you Minnie Aldo I
just got back home and this is what I
see god dammit I hope they're not gonna
be pissed at me tomorrow I mean it's not
I already said I'm shooting him I think
people want the announcement to come at
the right time media is so tricky you
know you can use you can use them for
your own benefit or they can use you I
feel like I just got used I love the
rush though birch is great let's look at
the passive-aggressive comments because
that's what happens every time good for
him I don't care cuz well then well what
do you know I misjudge stiver
challengers you win this round I got my
call time for DES Martin what are you
doing okay so tomorrow I start better
Papa 6:00 p.m. that's crazy
6:00 p.m. okay tomorrow's gonna be weird
we should plan something to do and
during the day well my said what do you
got there oh it's my baby no no you're
really good are you me but there's
something wrong with this mechanism Wow
what with these huge bugs here up there
I don't know how to reach it
yeah you're right shorty any it's time
for me to be a man what what yeah [ __ ]
you guys right what are you go on floor
and the floor and the floor is it your
dad in the corner up there what thank
you oh it's moving sculpting
okay that was another day I had so much
fun today I'm always nervous before
these things but there are a lot of fun
I'm having a blast in LA and I'm loving
how much you bros are loving the vlog so
thank you so much I really really
appreciate it thank you so much for
watching this and I'll see you tomorrow
as always Bros stay awesome alright so
we're heading to Little Tokyo never been
a little Tokyo before now we can be
weeps I wish for eternal great poops
they miss